working with the living legend a legend
All Over Hong Kong was amazing every day
I couldn't wait to come on the set to
see
Jackie Chan
Chris Tucker I don't lie in the
beginning first time I met him I said
look at that guy why why he's keep
talking what the hell did you just say
he's so fast
[Music]
and later on using the movie
and he was lay on the set I was late
most of the time but when I got there
Jackie was there waiting with his legs
crossing
one day he come techie can you come
later you make me look bad I know this
is my job but he didn't complain you
know I was this young kid he went with
the flow
which one of y'all kicking me but now
Chris every day on the set night I
really like it
where are you I'm in Hong Kong okay when
you come to United States they're coming
soon wake up join it together I said
okay okay
what the hell you doing
[Music]
you cannot speak English